herr seehofer ich würde einmal bei ihnen
anfang denn in den letzten minuten kann
man sagen hat es eine spannende
entwicklung gegeben sie haben gestern
angekündigt sie wollen vor dem
hintergrund der gewalt gegen polizisten
vor dem hintergrund dieses
gewaltexzesses gegen polizisten unter
anderem anzeige erstatten gegen eine
kolumnistin der taz die polizisten mit
müll gleichgesetzt hatte die geschrieben
hat polizisten gehören auf die
mülldeponie das sei der einzig richtige
ort für sie nun sagte eben der sprecher
der bundeskanzlerin in der
bundespressekonferenz sie seien darüber
mit der bundeskanzlerin noch im gespräch
und ihr sprecher sagte es sei darüber
noch nicht entschieden wird diese
anzeige geben oder wird es sie nicht
geben zunächst möchte ich noch auf eine
äußerung des bundespräsidenten hinweisen
der sehr klare bord gefunden hat auch zu
dieser problematik der entsorgung von
polizeibeamten und auch diesen termin in
stuttgart werde ich in meinem
ministerium nach berlin fliegen und dann
dort die dicke abschließend besprechen
abschließend besprechen heißt dann aber
es gibt doch noch keine entscheidung
darüber richtig
ja ich habe die absicht aber ich muss
natürlich mit meinen juristen darüber
reden und dann erfolgt heute nachmittag
und haben ihre juristen ihnen vorher
nicht gesagt ob das erfolg versprechend
sein könnte oder oder ob man es lieber
bleiben lassen sollte natürlich haben
wir vorher darüber gesprochen aber ich
finde es gibt da einige passagen die
doch aus meiner sicht über die presse
und meinungsfreiheit hinausgehen die ser
8 das ist ein hohes gut in einer
demokratie aber es gibt auch punkte mit
denen ich einfach nicht leben kann in
diesem artikel
und deshalb werde ich das nochmal
nachmittag besprechen und dann werden
wir eine entscheidung endgültige
entscheidung treffen
presse und meinungsfreiheit ein ganz
wichtiges thema wir wollen darauf gleich
noch einmal zurückkommen aber jetzt
vielleicht einmal an den baden
württembergischen innenminister thomas
strobl die frage wir haben
es handle sich bei den gewalttätern um
mitglieder einer sogenannten party und
eventszene ist das wirklich die richtige
wortwahl party und eventszene das klingt
eigentlich eher als hätten die sich da
ja eine schöne veranstaltung organisiert
und werden dann von der polizei gestört
worden ist das wirklich eine szene hat
das was mit partys und events zu tun
damit sollte zum ausdruck gebracht
werden dass wir jedenfalls bis zur
stunde keine hinweise darauf haben dass
es sich um eine politisch motivierte
aktion handelt das also beispielsweise
linksextremisten oder rechtsextremisten
hinter diesen gewalttätigen
ausschreitungen
ausschreitungen stecken
sie haben schon ganz recht das klingt so
ein bisschen harmlos ich möchte klar
sagen das ist ein militanter mob gewesen
der in der nacht von samstag auf sonntag
in stuttgart sein gewalttätiges unwesen
getrieben hat und unabhängig von der
motivation
das geht gar nicht gewalt gegen sachen
gewalt gegen personen gewalt gegen
polizistinnen und polizisten darf es
nicht geben wir werden die randalierer
mit allem was uns der rechtsstaat zur
verfügung stellt verfolgen und zur
rechenschaft ziehen
natürlich ist das was dort in stuttgart
geschehen ist auch jetzt besonders in
den sozialen medien ein riesen thema und
dieses wort party und eventszene wird er
besonders heiß diskutiert manche fühlen
sich erinnert an das was in köln in der
silvesternacht passiert ist das da erst
ein bisschen beschädigt worden ist dass
es erst da sei eigentlich gar nichts
passiert dass dieses wort verharmlost
muss man da in diesen zeiten besonders
vorsichtig sein ob man so ein wort party
und eventszene verwendet wir
verharmlosen gar nichts führen benennen
die dinge klar beim namen
wir sagen auch klar dass so etwas nicht
geht
es wird ja viel von der liberalität in
stuttgart gesprochen das finde ich
ganz in ordnung aber diese liberalität
die hat natürlich ihre grenzen und diese
grenzen sind überschritten wenn
straftaten begangen werden insbesondere
wenn gewalt ausgeübt wird aber es wird
im stuttgarter schlosspark auch in
zukunft keine offene drogenszene geben
wir sind und werden nicht der görlitzer
park sondern das wird auch in zukunft
mit aller konsequenz gemacht streng nach
dem motto wehret den anfängen also gegen
party hat niemand etwas aber im rahmen
der gesetze und selbstverständlich ohne
gewalt und dort wo das nicht eingehalten
werden wird die baden-württembergische
landespolizei selbstverständlich
einschreiten mit allen konsequenzen
ich bin sehr froh darüber dass wir eine
exzellente polizei in baden württemberg
haben möchte auch an dieser stelle mich
bei allen polizistinnen und polizisten
für ihren schwierigen und gefährlichen
einsatz am vergangenen wochenende
gedanken
herr seehofer schwieriger und
gefährlicher einsatz ist vielleicht das
richtige stichwort wir haben gesehen ein
mann der mit ausgestrecktem bein mit dem
jump kick in einen polizisten hinein
springt der gerade ja seine arbeit macht
er gerade einen anderen randalierer
fixiert heißt es glaube ich in der
sprache was ist das für ein klima das
wir inzwischen in deutschland haben so
reflexhaft auf die polizei losgegangen
wird ja genau diese frage geht es mir
persönlich schon seit langer zeit im
grunde seitdem ich im amt bin dieser
gewaltexzesse in stuttgart ist für sich
genommen schon schlimm genug aber wir
haben seit langer zeit ein sehr starkes
ansteigen der gewalt gegenüber
polizeibeamten und nebenbei auch noch
gegenüber feuerwehren gegenüber
rettungsorganisationen
das heißt es gibt einen teil in der
bevölkerung
es ist nicht die mehrheit der
bevölkerung bereitet sich die mehrheit
der bevölkerung besteht auf unseren
demokratischen boden aber es gibt einen
teil der die politik der die polizei als
gegner und feinde betrachtet und deshalb
kämpfe ich schon seit langem um zwei
dinge das eine ist dass wir als politik
aber auch die gesamte bevölkerung der
polizei das gefühl vermitteln wir stehen
hinter ihrer schwierigen aufgabe
und das zweite ist und darauf hoffe ich
jetzt im fall von stuttgart dass die
justiz den tätern die überführt werden
auch eine harte strafe zukommen reste
der nur eine bestrafung solcher
gewalttaten führt auch zur prävention
für die zukunft noch einmal zu dem klima
herr seehofer saskia esken sagt es gebe
latenten rassismus in unseren
polizeibehörden die taz kolumne über die
haben wir eben gesprochen was meinen sie
führt diese form von klima direkt zur
gewalt gegen polizisten
ich glaube die summe aus all diesen
einlassungen erhöht jedenfalls die
bereitschaft sich der polizei in den weg
zu stellen in welcher form auch immer
und deshalb ist es wichtig wie ich
gerade sagte der polizei zu vermitteln
wir stehen gerade als politiker hinter
unserer polizei ich sage immer wir
müssen die schützen die uns schützen und
deshalb geht es auf der einen seite um
die bekämpfung der direkten gewalt aber
es geht auf der anderen seite auch darum
sich zu mäßigen in den worten weil aus
den worten nicht selten dann auch taten
gewalttätige taten entstehen und darüber
muss sich jeder im klaren sein dass es
da in den zusammenhang gibt
der bundesgeschäftsführer der grünen
herr keller sagt dass ihre anzeige ihre
mögliche anzeige muss man ja jetzt sagen
ein angriff auf die pressefreiheit sei
und vergleicht sie unter anderem
deswegen mit viktor orban
haben sie was mit orban gemeinsam und
ist das ein angriff auf die
pressefreiheit
ja ich habe zur pressefreiheit alles
hinreichend gesagt ich bin ein großer
anhänger der presse und der
meinungsfreiheit die meinungsfreiheit
leiste ich mir selbst auch aber es gibt
grenzen und diese kolumne überschreitet
an verschiedenen stellen die grenzen und
deshalb sollten sich die grünen lieber
einmal selbst fragen ob sie in diesen
fragen alles richtig machen es gibt ja
auch in berlin im land berlin ein
antidiskriminierungsgesetz das ja auch
die politik die nicht die politik
sondern die polizei und einen gewissen
generalverdacht gestellt also eine die
unschuldsvermutung der polizisten war im
einsatz wird weggenommen und sie müssen
dann beweisen dass sie nicht
diskriminiert haben das ist auch ein ja
eine schlimme reichen stellung ich kann
für die unionsgeführten länder sagen
dass in der innenministerkonferenz alle
unionsgeführten länder sich gegen dieses
gesetz gestellt haben
und der senator von der innensenator von
berlin hat uns erklärt dieses gesetz in
berlin gilt nur für die
landesbediensteten in berlin und nicht
für die übrige polizei die in berlin mal
zur unterstützung kommt ich werde mich
diese woche noch mit dem senator treffen
und dann müssen wir weitere einzelheiten
besprechen damit diese zweifel
ausgeräumt werden
herr strobel noch einmal zu ihnen die
polizei hat gestern auch etwas über die
herkunft der täter gesagt und das ist
natürlich ein ein heikles thema kann man
sagen haben die krawalle von
samstagnacht in stuttgart etwas mit
migration zu tun und möglichen
integrationsproblemen wenn wir sehen
dass mehr als die hälfte der
festgenommenen keinen deutschen pass
hatte wenn wir aber auch in den
vergangenheit in der vergangenheit immer
wieder gesehen haben dass angriffe auf
rettungskräfte auf krankenwagen auf
feuerwehrwagen besonders häufig zum
beispiel in klein muss bei damit
verbundenen straftaten stattfinden haben
wir da integrations versagen gesehen
haben wir da mangeln
und respekt gegenüber der polizei bei
menschen gesehen die zu uns gekommen
sind oder hat es damit nichts zu tun
jedenfalls sollten wir es mit multikulti
nicht übertreiben multikulti hat seine
klaren grenzen in den geltenden gesetzen
insbesondere in den strafgesetzen und da
gibt es jedenfalls in stuttgart und in
baden württemberg keinerlei rabatt ich
will vielleicht auch noch einmal sagen
herr reichelt warum gerade jetzt
ich habe am gestrigen sonntag sehr früh
darauf hingewiesen dass diese art der
gewalttätigen ausschreitungen eine neue
qualität jedenfalls in stuttgart und
baden württemberg hat diese randale
diese plünderungen von geschäften das
hat es bisher bei uns nicht gegeben
und das hat schon möglicherweise etwas
zu tun mit dem gesellschaftlichen umfeld
und auch mit den äußerungen der
bundesinnenminister hat darauf zu recht
hingewiesen die aus dem politischen
umfeld kommen es muss jetzt einfach
schluss sein mit dem beschimpfen unserer
polizei mit dem diskreditieren von
polizistinnen und polizisten ja bis hin
zur verleumdung unsere polizei in
baden-württemberg aber in ganz
deutschland hat dank und respekt
verdient für ihre arbeit sieben tage die
woche 24 stunden am tag und nicht hass
und verachtung und schon gar keine
gewalt das muss jetzt auch einmal klar
sein und ich hoffe dass diese
schrecklichen bilder aus stuttgart dem
einen oder anderen auch in der politik
die augen öffnen dass wir uns hinter
unsere polizei und vor unsere polizei zu
stellen haben auch dann im übrigen wenn
das eine schwierige lage ist herr
seehofer allahu akbar rufe hört man auf
den videos aus stuttgart was was sind
ihre gedanken dazu
ja das ist für mich alles unfassbar
schrecklich es ist einmalig und deshalb
müssen wir gemeinsam alles tun
deshalb bin ich heute hier in stuttgart
ich werde mir dann auch die schäden noch
ansehen gemeinsam mit thomas strobl dass
sich das nicht wiederholt das ist
eigentlich jetzt die größte aufgabe und
das werden wir nur erreichen wenn wir
unseren worten als politiker auch taten
folgen lassen
es wird häufig bei solchen dingen viel
gesagt aber nach einigen tagen beruhigt
es sich dann wieder und es erfolgt nicht
das notwendige ich habe ein paar punkte
genannt die aus meiner sicht notwendig
sind die geändert werden müssen
insbesondere auch die konsequenz der
justiz gegenüber den straftätern und was
die migration angeht da werde ich mir
erst ein urteil erlauben wenn ich die
genaueren ermittlungsergebnisse kenne
ich kenne auch die zahl die sie genannt
haben aber es kommt immer darauf an ist
man hier geboren welchen weg hat man
hier gemacht ist man bereits polizei
fällig gewesen
und so weiter und so fort und dann muss
man darüber ganz offen reden was die
ermittlungen der polizei ergeben haben
abschließende frage an sie beide an den
bundesinnenminister und den
innenminister von baden-württemberg
es gibt dieses video was vermutlich
wirklich vielen menschen in diesem land
die ein entspanntes und freundliches
verhältnis zur polizei haben und die
polizei als tatsächlich freund und
helfer sehen was diesen menschen nahe
geht und das ist dieser dieser job kick
dieser sprung in den polizisten hinein
einmal vielleicht von ihnen beiden ihre
ganz persönlichen gedanken was ist ihnen
durch den kopf gegangen als sie dieses
video das erste mal gesehen haben herr
strobl der arme kollege habe ich gedacht
im ersten moment und war wirklich sehr
wütend über über diese aggression und ja
diese nackte gewalt die hier zum
ausdruck kommt jemand so mit dem fuß an
zu springen und zu traktieren und ich
war dann kurze zeit später habe ich mir
gedacht gott sei dank rüsten wir unsere
polizistinnen und polizisten in baden
württemberg sehr gut aus dass das
notwendig ist sieht man auch in dieser
bildsequenz weil man sieht welchen
angriffen und welcher körperlichen
welcher physischen gewalt als sie
ausgesetzt sind es war mir immer ein
persönliches anliegen dass unsere
polizeibeamtinnen und polizeibeamten
eine optimale ausrüstung haben und klar
ist im übrigen auch geworden wir
brauchen mehr polizei und deswegen hoffe
ich in zukunft weiter auf die
unterstützung aus dem politischen
bereich aus dem landtag von baden
württemberg dass wir auch in zukunft ist
in den letzten jahren ja sehr
erfolgreich gemacht haben ausreichend
junge polizistinnen und polizisten
einstellen sie optimal ausbilden sie
optimal ausrüsten das ist ein teil der
notwendigen rechtsstaatlichen antwort
auf solche bilder
abschließende worte von ihnen herr
seehofer
was waren ihre gedanken und ja
vielleicht auch ihre gefühlslage als sie
dieses video das erste mal gesehen haben
reichelt ich bin normalerweise ein
gelassener und ruhiger mensch aber da
war ich wirklich entsetzt und aufgewühlt
und mir war klar dieses bild macht
deutlich dass die gewalt nicht von der
polizei ausgeht sie erfüllt ihre
aufgaben und muss auch manchmal
unmittelbaren zwang anwenden aber am
gesetz vorbei gewalttätig werden unsere
polizisten nicht sind
wenige in der bevölkerung die zu dieser
gewalt und feindseligkeit gegenüber der
polizei bereit sind und deshalb müssen
wir die polizei noch stärker schützen so
wie es thomas strobl gerade gesagt hat
ich habe vor wenigen wochen angeordnet
dass die bundespolizei die hier nur mit
einer kleinen stärke vertreten war
weil sie angefordert wurde dass die
bundespolizei an neuralgischen punkten
nicht mehr alleine oder zu zweit
auftritt sondern dass jede streife
künftig aus drei personen besteht weil
damit der eigenschutz der beamten
stärker gewährleistet werden kann und
was thomas strobl sagte wir müssen
weiter daran arbeiten die polizei
präsenz zu verstärken das heißt auch
mehr personal und auch immer wieder nach
modernsten maßstäben ausbilden also mein
vertrauen hat die polizei früher in
bayern und jetzt die bundespolizei sind
immerhin fast 50.000 frauen und männer
und ich sage noch einmal die sind eine
stabilitätsanker für unseren rechtsstaat
und das was wir jetzt in stuttgart
erlebt haben
aber auch darüber hinaus es war ja nicht
der einzige vorfall in stuttgart ihrer
rede an göttingen
da gab es ja auch massiven widerstand
gegen die polizei in diesem quartier
blog das ist insgesamt und weil der seit
monaten anhält ein erleben signal für
unseren rechtsstaat und darauf müssen
wir die antworten geben ist auch da eine
wiederholung durch taten nicht durch
schöne worte für einige stunden und dann
geht alles wieder wie bisher weiter
das waren der bundesinnenminister horst
seehofer unter baden württembergische
innenminister thomas strobl uns live
zugeschaltet aus stuttgart ihnen
herzlichen dank nach stuttgart und von
dieser stelle vielleicht auch einmal im
namen von bild an all die polizistinnen
und polizisten da draußen vielen dank
für ihren dienst und dafür dass sie auf
uns aufpassen und damit zurück zu dir
nommen